good evening I'm Robert stern the Dean
of the school of architecture and on
behalf of the school I'm pleased to
welcome you to this evening's
conversation and book signing the book
Lewis icon in conversation and edited by
Jules David Brown and Karen E Genovese
and published by the Yale University
Press is a remarkable document beautiful
to look at and amazing in its
scholarship a true labor of love
Lewis icon holds a special place in the
history of the School of Architecture
when Conn joined the faculty in 1947 he
was better known as a socially engaged
architect specializing in low-cost
housing then as the internationally
revered advocate of a resurrected
monumentality that he would later become
in the late 1940s the department of
architecture then part of the School of
Fine Arts was rebuilding its programs
following upon the widespread
repudiation of the bozo pedagogy that
had been Yale's mainstay for 50 years
there was a new dean Charles Sawyer who
was influenced by Josef Albers the
former Bauhaus master Albert's would
himself joined the faculty as chairman
of the department of art in 1949 when at
the same time Kahn was instrumental in
seeing to the appointment as chair of
the architecture department of the
highly respected Bo's are trained
modernist convert architect George
out.when Eero Saarinen turned down the
invitation to design the long-delayed
extension to the Yale art gallery
arguing that he was too busy to take it
on I've never heard of an argument more
ridiculousness
how in a remarkable act of mentoring
pushed Khan's name forward the art
gallery extension
proved to be crucial to Kahn's career
and to the history of modern
architecture Lewis kind Recon remained
on the architecture faculty until 1958
and afterwards occasionally visited the
School of Architecture to lecture in
1969 a year of student turmoil at Yale
and elsewhere Gahan began the design for
a second museum at Yale the Center for
British art consideration of which is
what brings us together here tonight but
enough with history it is now my
pleasure to turn the platform over to my
colleague Amy Myers since 2002 director
of the Yale Center for British art who
has done such so much to enliven its
programs to reach out to students and
the public and most significantly in the
context of tonight's proceedings to see
to it that Khan's
masterwork is treated with the same care
and respect that is lavished on the very
many master works of art in its that it
contains following this evenings program
please join our speakers in the
architecture gallery which is on the
second floor of this building for a
reception now please join me in
welcoming Amy Myers to the podium
thank you for your kind words Bob we are
so grateful to you and our colleagues at
the School of Architecture for your
support of our efforts to maintain and
conserve our building to the highest
standards indeed among the gifts that
the center's founder paul mellon gave to
Yale
none apart from the collection is
greater than the building itself
appreciating our building is an
architectural achievement that must be
preserved we recently published lois
icon and the Yale Center for British art
a conservation plan edited by Peter and
skip and Steven G with the assistance of
our Deputy Director Constance Clement we
hope that the publication will serve as
a model for similar efforts in this
country where such planning for the
future is uncommon and almost never
happens in relation to modern buildings
in preparing that book the editors in
the center's Building Conservation
Committee had the benefit of
recollections and advice from Jules
prowl the first director of the centre
who initially had proposed Kahn as the
architect and who served as the client
for the design and construction of the
building on behalf of the university I
also have to say a personal word I among
others at the centre was a student under
Jules writing my dissertation here at
Yale just as the centre opened and there
could have been no greater pleasure than
to come to study under Jules at a time
when the great satisfaction of creating
the institution was so potent I think
not just for Jules but for all of us and
the great collection and building was
deployed to inspire here at Yale and I
owe my great debt of thanks to jules as
well following his retirement from
full-time teaching in 1999 Jules
returned to the center as senior
research fellow and he has devoted
himself to recording the early history
of the center
and it's building as one of the most
important scholarly projects in which he
now is engaged
most recently he has focused on editing
the interviews that his former
associates in the history of our
department at Yale John Cook and Hyman
Klotz recorded with Kahn at the time
when initial planning for the center was
just getting underway and this is
extremely important and really is why
the book is so meaningful to us these
interviews the tapes of which are
preserved in the department of
manuscripts and archives at Sterling
Memorial Library here at Yale provide a
direct insight into Kahn's architectural
philosophy at the time when he was
developing his first concepts for the
subtor and so have particular value for
our institution the center is honored to
serve as the publisher of the interviews
that we launched tonight in concert was
the department of manuscripts and
archives at Sterling and the
architectural archives at the University
of Pennsylvania with which we have
worked so closely to produce this book
in editing the transcript of the
interviews views jewels considered
Kahn's expression of his philosophy with
the most careful attention to every word
and to the emphasis of every phrase
venting his own recollections of his
experience of working with Kahn on the
design of the center with a new
understanding of the architects own
thoughts during the period of their
collaboration he has been helped with
this meticulous intellectual process by
Karen Devon it denne of it who prepared
the verbatim transcript of the
interviews from which drools edited
transcript is drawn and who assisted him
in deciphering Kahn's words from tapes
that are almost half a century old their
work as a team has been exemplary and we
owe them an enormous debt of gratitude
for their persistence in retrieving for
us and for posterity a living record of
Kahn's word we will have the chance to
thank Jules momentarily but I would like
to ask
to stand so that she can be recognized
for this monumental achievement Karen
it's climbing thank you
we are on the same wavelength Bob always
we remain deeply grateful to John cook
and 100 cots for pursuing their original
interviews with Colin and of course to
con himself for the time he took to
reflect with them on the thinking that
underlay his projects both built and
unbuilt we are especially thankful to
cook and to Gertrude Klotz Heinrich
Lutz's Widow for their support of this
edition of the interviews and for their
encouragement to pursue a work that
would enable cons words to be well both
read heard and appreciated beyond the
condensed version of the interviews
published in their aftermath in the book
conversations with the architects we
have the honor and pleasure of having
John with us this evening and I also
would like to ask him to stand so that
he might be recognized by us
we also are indebted to Christine
Weidman director of yells Department of
manuscripts and archives sterling
Memorial Library and Nancy thorn
archivist and William Whittaker curator
and Collections Manager at the
architectural archives of the University
of Pennsylvania for their great
assistance with the project on so many
fronts and for their collaborative
spirit
we also are pleased that they can be
with us this evening
a print version of the transcript of the
verbatim interviews has been deposited
with the taped interviews as well as
with the architectural archives at the
University of Pennsylvania and the
institutional archive of the Yale Center
for British art as we have the center
find ourselves in the midst of our
current project to conserve our great
building addressing mechanical systems
that now are almost 40 years old and
warmth the worn fabric of our actively
used galleries and auditorium
we are grateful not only for our deeply
researched conservation plan but also
for these interviews which illuminate
further cons approach toward the design
of the extraordinary structure in which
we have the privilege to work with the
publication of this thoughtful edition
of the interviews and the making
available of the writ verbatim
transcript we hope that the stewards of
other con buildings and scholars of his
work will find the architects own words
to be of equal value
I now am delighted to welcome my
colleague Ava Lisa pehla pehla Conan to
the podium an assistant professor at the
School of Architecture and a fine
scholar of Kahn in her own right who
will give us some brief remarks about
the architect and we'll welcome Jules
and Alec Purvis to begin what promises
to be a rich and most satisfying
conversation a Felisa
can you see a slide yes okay as a preamp
limp to the main event of tonight's main
event I would like to talk briefly about
Khan's tenure at Yale which lasted from
1947 to 1957
I will attain that this period was an
important one for cars intellectual and
artistic development not least because
of people like Josef Albers and his wife
Annie Albers who arrived on campus two
years later a loving couple so let's
begin
we can't began upon his arrival he was
like Bob said one of the first hires
after the university had become to
modernize its art curriculum under the
leadership of Charles Sawyer the Dean of
the School of Fine Arts
Eero Saarinen was one committee member
in this effort he was hired to teach
upper-level Studios one of the first of
which in the fall of 1948 was entitled
National Center for UNESCO where the
second we go here it was the first one
to implement the so-called collab
collaborative design problem which
brought together architects painters and
sculptures to work I mean students of
those fields to work on a collaborative
project as you can see the architectural
language clearly favored and supported
by Kahn was very kind of structurally
expressive monumental scale work and you
can see in the world there the kind of
mural paintings by their art students
two years into his job
Kant took a leading role in helping to
convince there are Albers to take a job
at Yale in 1949
the two joined forces in a studio taught
in in the academic year of 1949 and 1950
to teach a studio entitled an idea
center for plastics Cohn was the chief
critic and coordinator and came up with
the idea and Albers served as an
in-house critic the new material as you
can tell from these slides proved to be
rather challenging to work on and the
results varied both in style and quality
it comes as therefore no surprise that
when Albers came to critique the work
map being a master of restraint he was
not very happy about the results the
first indication that Cohen was going
through a major shift in his own
artistic sensibility comes with the set
of drawings and pastels with names such
as abstract Plains and steps and
transparency
number one with intersecting and
overlapping planes and surfaces executed
in black and white they pair striking
similarity to outburst this structural
constellation series which can had seen
a year later when he visited Albers in
Cincinnati where he was working on the
series and he is The Smoking Gun can
holding one of them one that he had
selected as a retirement gift to the
departing Dean of the architecture
school at that time Department of
Architecture cursory George Howe so here
you see chose how in the middle I think
that's the famous Medal don't let the
bastards let you down wear you down you
see Vincent Scully next to next to him
holding the middle and here one of the
series I couldn't quite decipher which
one he is holding but this is
somewhat similar so another important
shift comes during current residency at
the American Academy in Rome that lasted
from December 50 to August 1951 when
current gains an interest in pre-modern
architecture such extended historical
view and this is actually again I this
connection with with the Albers here as
a subtext Albers was of course
interested in travelled often to Mexico
to to do a photography of this type of
architecture such extended historical
perspective was shared with several
other prominent faculty members in
departments of art history and
philosophy such as Benson Scully and
Jorge Kubler here are some books that
they were working on at the same time
that emphasized this type of historical
perspective there was also a philosopher
paul weiss who statement from 1945 here
every existent has passed all have come
to be every existence has its effects on
future is echoed in cars declaration at
the Aspen design conference in 1961 what
was has always been what is has always
been what will be has always been yet is
it was Josef Albers Joseph and Annie
Albert who had perhaps the most profound
impact of current design philosophy
compare for example the restraint
geometry can adapt it into the Yale art
gallery and the spatial effect on Albers
is homage a square series series this is
of course the light well above the
staircase compare also
these quotes Albers writing in the Yale
alumni magazine in 1952 design is to
plan and organize to order to relate and
to control and no occurrence
text called order is that he published
in the third issue of perspective in
1955 five years later order is design is
for making in order form emerges out of
a system of construction in order is a
creative force in design is the means
where with what when with how much even
the notion of servant and served element
Kahn was famous for echoes out versus
words here a statement from actually
very early text by Allah pairs from
twenty-eight that says we know they no
longer differentiate essentially between
those elements which are carrying and
those which are carried between those
serving and those served which is echoed
in Kahn's author lore speech in from
1949 the space or the concept must
extend beyond harboring of the
mechanical services to include the
servant spaces adjoining spaces third I
compare these notes not to say you know
make a point about derivation but you
can see that these things were in the
air and that there was this incredibly
vital intellectual culture that can
truly enjoyed and and immersed himself
in finally I believe on the outbursts
had a major impact on currents thinking
about materials importantly as we know
she insisted on working with simple
traditional materials and techniques
believing that quotation traditions of
operation
which embody a set of law provides a
discipline that balances the high price
of creative ecstasy they hate it kind of
this or the personal gestural
architecture and also use of new
materials
tellingly her art form being was one of
the most oldest art forms in fact this
is interesting that when I can pop a
common publishes the plans for the Yale
art gallery for a first time in
perspective it's very beautiful hip
prints the different service system
ventilation electricity on
transparencies and let overlaps them to
create this type of effect of of weaving
now I went too far away and finally I
would make a point about again about
unease I'm missing a slide on the Albers
his words when he says when she says
being creative is perhaps not the desire
to do something but listening to what
with what that which wants to be done
the dictation of materials which is
again echoed by one of the town's most
famous statements that he makes in 1959
cm conference in Oslo again this is con
it is for the architect derived from the
very nature of things from his relations
what the thing wants to be so to
conclude it can left as a changed man
when he left the Yale and left behind
two magnificent buildings which bear
both the lessons that he learned during
his time at Yale so now to the main
event
I want to welcome to the stage choice
Brown the poor melon professor emeritus
at the history of our department and the
founding director of Yale Center for
British art and Alec Purvis who has been
a beloved faculty member and colleague
at the School of Architecture since 1976
who knows his car
over
right okay good evening everybody thanks
for coming and it is my pleasure to have
the opportunity to talk with Jules in a
in a rather somewhat more informal
setting than standing at a podium we've
had many conversations about Kahn over
the years as you can imagine in full
disclosure I should immediately tell you
that I was not a student of Kahn's
I did not know him he was here when I
first came to the School of Architecture
in 1958 he was working with the master's
class I saw him of course and heard him
from time to time but the only other
direct contact I had with him was when
we went down to Philadelphia as in the
third-year studio to design housing and
we spent an afternoon with him and it
was one of the most memorable occasions
that I can remember his demeanor his
character what he was talking about how
he expressed things was so powerful that
it resonated has continued to resonate
with me for a very long time but my
direct exposure to him was very limited
as opposed to the gentleman to my right
who probably knows him as well or better
than anybody else here having worked
with him hand in glove as it as it were
for many years since the inception of
the idea of the British Arts Center but
to begin at the beginning
Jules let me ask you how did you come to
become become director of the British
Art Center okay well it goes back to the
1960s in 1966 late in the year Paul
Mellon offered his gift of the British
art collection his British art
collection to Yale
along with funds to build the building
acquire the space and endow the
operation Kingman Brewster was president
of the University
and he formed the committee to plan for
what kind of a institution might house
that collection of it came to Yale at
that time I had just gotten tenure in
the history of art department and was
also curator of American art in the in
the Yale University art gallery
so my field was American art although my
dissertation was on John Singleton
Copley in England and I'd spent a year
in Hindman and and doesn't quite a bit
of work and in England and with that
aspect of English art Andrew Ricci was
the director of the Yale art gallery at
that time and he and I sort of won the
Subcommittee on the larger committee to
come up with plans for a building what
kind of wood in physical structure
should there be to accommodate the
collections the program so we put
together information on the kind of
square-footage requirements for the
painting collection from the Princeton
drawings to watercolors rare books
reference library and what would be
needed for curators for registrar all
the needs that a an institution might
have and what came up with a rough
estimate as to what the cost would be in
which poor Mellon was interested so that
report went in and was accepted by Yale
and by for Mellon and then early in 1968
came in booster asked me to be the
director of the center which was a
surprise and I was fairly reluctant
because I had a kind of captain's
paradise I was a professor of American
art and I was curator of American art
and I could use the collections just at
my fingertips which is no longer being
done
yeah but it was nice very nice the so I
was reluctant but Kingman was very
persuasive person and he felt very
strongly that it was important for the
director to be preferably a member of
the Yale faculty I was reluctant because
there are people who knew a lot more
about British art and there were people
who were more experienced at directly
museums I had been a graduate student at
Harvard at the Fogg had been assistant
to the director of the of the fog and
had been a curator so I had some
experience but there were really good
directors out there but as Bob alluded
to early on this was a time of turmoil
it was Vietnam war period there were a
lot of reservations about the idea of a
wealthy alumnus dropping a collection of
British art which was not that highly
regarded at the time on the university
because there were other other needs
that should be addressed but he wanted
the to pay the faculty to know that this
was an institution that was going to be
consistent with the intellectual mission
of the university so I said yes no I've
just then quite how did you come upon
choosing Khan and was it up to you to
make that recommendation well yes
surprisingly it was they don't do it
that way anymore no I think you know how
that came about and I think it was
because I mean when I was asked to be
director I was asked by Kingman and Paul
long came and I think Paul sort of felt
that I was maybe his person
yeah I supposed to have any committee
about which he was suspicious or having
a competition so yeah I asked kingdom
the first question I asked him really
was yeah okay i'm director of the center
what's my responsibility pacifically
about the building he said well you're
the client Yale University is the owner
Paul melons the donor so on so you're
what you should do is do some research
figure it out and make a recommendation
to the university as to an architect and
that'll either be approved or not by the
corporation so I said about doing that
meeting traveling but I brought with me
quite a bit of baggage on my time at
Harvard but the at that time the over
the dominant idea for museum
architecture was to create a kind of
open area loft space in which the person
strolling installation could divide the
space in whatever way they wanted in
order to put things where they wanted
and to use artificial illumination so
again so they would have complete
control over it I didn't I didn't
believe in that and because of my
experience at the fog where I had
installed some exhibitions and took
courses in with John and I worked
closely with John Coolidge was a
director I can talk but I felt that
objects works were the best on under
daylight natural light if you could
control it for ultraviolet and the
damaging effects of daylight and that's
you know paintings are very tough things
and they've survived for centuries under
natural light and that's where they were
painted under natural light so my
preference was for daylight it could be
that was a very high priority the second
one had to do with rooms the instead of
a
undifferentiated space I wanted to have
a well-designed
room against which whoever is installing
the exhibition had to work against the
discipline of that room and I and I it
seemed to me that the place is where I
have most enjoyed looking at works of
art were domestic places domestic
museums particularly the Philips gallery
in Washington but the Frick the freer
the gardener and even the fog itself as
a Palazzo but still was domestic and had
that room like quality so those things I
wrote them up in a for the pre program
which was sort of general philosophical
ideas and it talked about wanting those
kinds of things also talked about this
quadrant of the university as being the
Arts quadrant and what what would be in
here and and the fact that the building
needed to be humane and not boodle to
make any immediate reference system a
series of things the one thing that's in
there that was not following things I
didn't want also was I didn't want a a
cold palate surface and the facade and I
was very surprised when we ended up with
the metal facade so you know they've
narrowed it down to did you have any
trouble convincing the university which
they knew con from the art gallery well
and also or Paul Mellon for that matter
of yeah well they they did I asked Paul
if he had any preferences just you know
as far as in art they said well I know I
am teh best he had done
choked the art gallery at showed he was
doing the deal at the National Gallery
he said but you know I'm not gonna have
to live in the building Yale is so you
should you should make the day so he was
he was not interfering in that regard
all but both he and and Yale were well
aware of cons reputation for never
having brought a building in on time or
on budget but they also knew he was
afraid
and so they and they did and I I don't I
don't know the what the corporation was
the building committee did to take them
to see for instance this bill well yeah
well when I went to see you I'm like to
lose the office and I interviewed him
and in the course of that interview one
thing that we may get to mention Dennis
book yeah the one thing I we didn't want
was monumentality the tenor of the times
people were really opposed to buildings
that were monumental museum that what
has steps like the Metropolitan or the
National Gallery which would really do a
lot of damage in New Haven maybe I can
just mention that I don't want to go on
too long but New Haven by the plan of it
the commercial development of New Haven
from Church Street West is one-sided
because of the green and then yeah and
then Yale University of the whole campus
then the art gallery and on the other
side of the street from the old art
gallery and the new art gallery there
was to be a another gallery that would
just cut the whole commercial
development toward the west and be
damaging to the city so people did not
want that and so I was a little
concerned because when I went into cons
office there was a cross from his desk
was this eight-foot wide knowing Oh lots
of they compressive and planning for
Venice and that was precisely what we
didn't want but everything else one was
there also some oh yeah you want the
what do you wanna do we'll come back to
but but I just wanted to mention that
not only
with the continuity of the shopping and
the commercial be interrupted but really
it would have been the first time that
Yael moved across Chapel Street
yep that's a very important point and
was there any Student Involvement home
late yes particularly from the
architecture students they were very
much interested very much involved and
they were they were very bright and not
really unfriendly but they wanted to be
involved and they want to be informed a
little bit aggressive but not terribly
spoken and they were concerned a number
of things but that the word
monumentality is one that comes in and
one of cons first essays was entitled
monumentality but it was mining
mentality on his terms rather than
something rather different they would
they didn't like the wall of the of the
art gallery go the new art gallery you
know this one the con building they felt
that was that was monumental and turned
his back on on the street and con when
he was asked about it later on and in in
the book because John and Heinrich asked
him about that said so it's not
monumental at all I put these string
courses in there because that break that
prevents the with whatever really
bothered me really the way it is was
those other windows it's the the windows
in the sport and the Edgerton sward out
building the old art gallery which are
enormous he said you know how do you
make a window next to that he said so I
put the windows on the other side
yeah I should I should add apropos that
that their John's book conversations
with architects which includes ten
and/or eight interviews with different
architects has taken these tapes of
these long conversations and and done a
terrific job of editing them but editing
them way down that interview is like 35
pages whereas the actual tapes run to
260 and so there are lots of things
which turned up in this book which were
news to me and one of them was that I
never heard him say anything about how
to deal with those windows I've been
thinking about that recently too because
it seems to me that in and when we get
to the if we get to the current British
short Center for that facade which is a
major element and that deserves some
conversation but he solves that problem
of the windows yeah it's the first time
he really does windows yeah a long time
but a comic comes out of his own
philosophy he has a real reason for
doing what he did I love them but I love
the comment he made about the the
problem we had with that wall he said he
made it blank I think I'm right because
there's a combination of deference and
indecision each other
yeah but there's another building he had
- I'm just gonna move past this one
there's another building he had to deal
with yeah yeah and I should also say
that all of the comments about this
building do not show up in John's text
but do show up in spades in this one yes
well it's a it's a fascinating thing one
of the questions was how well just to
back up a little bit about your earlier
point about moving across channel Street
and breaching that boundary yeah Chapel
Street had always been considered sort
of an informal boundary for Yale and now
Yale was expanding and there was real
concern about that on the part of the
south of the city and an opposition to
it and particularly in the early
planning for the center it was going to
have a bridge across Neville Street and
that made it all the more obvious con
but being aware of that site I uh I was
like well he'll be really make something
particularly interested in his own
earlier building and this is later
building he wasn't he'd never talked
about this word out building the the old
Art Gallery although that was very much
on his mind but then the new art gallery
had been under Andrew Richie and Richie
came had been curator at the Museum of
Modern Art the Yale art gallery was
fairly sleepy prior to that and Andrew
wanted to bring in big donors big
supporters any boomer Yale collectors
and so he tried to make it look like the
museum Modern Art and he covered the
wall interior walls beautiful interior
walls with with drywall and and and also
enclosed the staircase and Luke was
curious about that
and we had to go over there sometime
because the print room prints and
drawings in the center was going to be
in the same height and orientation as
the print room in the art gallery so we
wanted to see what the effect of light
coming in so we would walk over there he
would never look up you just walk right
through those galleries and right past
the staircase into the elevator up and
out it's it's my conviction now that the
conversation that taking place is not
with his building but with this one if
it's with the Rudolph building which he
clearly didn't like and he there isn't a
book where it just comes out of his
philosophy as it develops when he his
his his orientation is that we may get
to a - but just philosophically he draws
a distinction between fact and truth and
fact is what the physical world gives
you nature gives you the universe gives
you we're all facts raw material truth
is what humans require and so when he
builds a building he asks nature you
know I've got to build this building and
we wanted to do this client was doing
you know make it formula and then the
nature says well I'll do what I can you
know I can only go so far and then the
architect comes in and and inserts into
that human needs and and another one of
con is always doing binaries yeah
another one that in fact mean at one
point you said that every problem can be
solved by a binary which is incoming at
the be at the dawn of the computer age
is a very
so so the architect you don't humanizes
it so he said you know I I think from
nature and then make it suitable for
human need this building he says is a
willful building and what he says in a
sense but what poor Widow is doing is
imposing his will on what he wants in
that building and of course when the
building was being constructed and
you'll remember if I remember I was a
fantastic piece of sculpture a fabulous
thing just incredible and but there are
things that you would know better
structurally that of the who objected to
that where the beams meet the column
sometimes they're on top sometimes the
cannon inside they do different kinds of
things he would never do that there was
an order you follow that of order and
stick with it so he felt that that this
was the architect imposing his will says
he's saying Rudolf was a willful
architect and I'm not over someone's
anything bad about it no I know he said
I don't want it I wanted to yeah but but
he also says that it's not undisciplined
I think that that suggested by either by
John or by Henry
it's an undisciplined building because
no it's not an under sort of building
but it has a lot of wilful things in it
that's correct and it's a kind of coming
together of shapes I think is the phrase
that he used to describe it I have I
have to say just memory my first two
years in school were in the in the art
gallery building not this one
you know the Kahn building and my last
two years even here of the fourth floor
of the article yeah yeah and and for us
and at that generation anyway those
folks working in that building at that
time I think I could speak for all of
them maybe not but for most of them it
was a great place to start because
everything was so didactic it was so
clear if you had a question all you had
to do was look around a certain kind of
question anyway about
building and material other kinds of
questions were not so answered so
clearly by that building but those were
was a great place to begin but I have to
say that when this building was under
construction we would come over at night
and climb around it which was a pretty
stupid thing to do because
extraordinarily dangerous but it was
thrilling I mean as you said it was and
was fascinating to have the experience
of both buildings and to admire and to
really cherish both of them but they
speak to different parts of you but both
of them very eloquently let's just see
what's oh yeah no that's interesting
here the wait am i we have I go there
yet no it's not there it will be yeah so
it's a final word of the Rudolf belief
is when Khan made it presented his
perspective drawing to the city to get
approval to be able to proceed to build
the the center he takes it from the from
the corner of chapel and high streets
looking down Chapel Street Khan didn't
really believe it that cars should be on
the street yes I so it's it's just an
ASIS pedestrian through way he thought
cars should either be under the street
or else way up high and that's at the
street level really belong to the people
and to society for commercial weather
for commercial use but for hospitals
schools any kind of things that serve
general public public needs but by
making that the perspect to join the way
he does it takes the Rudolf building
which is really a very strong powerful
building he just shrinks it down to this
little thing at the end of its really
compare like you can party if I sort of
tucked behind the trees and in the
clouds it's very I mean
however the eldorado was very clear to
see the other thing which he talks about
a lot in the book is the way in which
the lower floor of the building
belongs to the street and essentially
particularly in an institutional
building the
as part of the street and it could even
rise for a couple of floors as
commercial in certain circumstances he
speaks a lot about streets in the book
and you know he and John and I'm not
getting the conversations about from
their own lives as to how they like it
when there would be a carnivals in the
summer and be and all the tables of
grandmas they'd be very happy with the
tables that are now I haven't found the
art gallery love it
let's talk for a minute about the tasks
that you faced and first of all why did
you feel the need to do this and what
were the hurdles I mean you were
presented with tapes as Amy said which
are not recent which were probably in
terrible shape so what was involved and
actually getting to the material itself
and getting the transcripts that that
Karen did for you oh well we like John
very generously gave that gave those
tapes to manuscripts and archives yeah
and went over and talked to Chris quite
a music head of it and add to explore
the possibility of doing something like
this and then we had a meeting with Amy
and a few other people and Karen to
explore it and they were enthusiastic
about doing that but we were not able to
use the tapes because the tapes were too
fragile to use fiddle so we made CDs
from that and CC Clement was very
helpful in getting those for us and
that's what we worked then it was just
an intramural side stories that they we
I spent one summer really look at
headphones listening and and transfer
trying to make this condensed version
which I did out of it but but I came
back and I told Chris that you know
there's a lot of the words I can't
really understand there and she said
well you know she said
we can always have them Firenze forensic
ly edited what does that mean you know
there's a little Russian I don't I was
finally absolutely there was a little
little story about that but she told
them she says because I asked the same
question what that means she said well
one day the FBI came here to manuscripts
and archives they said we hear that you
have that at the time of the Kent State
massacre that one of the students hung a
microphone out of his dorm window and
recorded what was just going on out
there and the FBI wanted to know what
because the National Guard was there and
the students were coming up and putting
flowers and their rifles and somebody
shot and then a couple of students were
killed they wanted to know whether the
order was given to fire mm-hmm words
wasn't done under a command or was it
just somebody lost their nerve so they
couldn't hear it on the tape of the
student record so they they said well we
can forensically edit it and they did it
and they did it and they didn't make him
back and they heard the word fire and
that's that's that's what it meant so
that Chris said yeah well we'll take the
tape we'll have it forensic we edited it
at our expense
and and they did so I listened I went
through the whole thing again the next
summer and and recorded and edited it
and we kind of saved me for a number of
hours and I would have made those words
I had misunderstood maybe we what about
hearing a little bit of it because I
think that everybody yeah oh yeah just
just to say no go yeah that's a great
idea because we'll give you an idea of
Conn's very distinctive manner of
speaking and you'll get a sense of why
had needs to be sort of condensed and
what I was trying to do knowing that ya
know having worked with him we I knew
that he could be very practical but when
he would speak he's either a public
lecture or two
you see we get very elaborate very
poetic and yet when I would see him with
work the charcoal and ham working over
the paper a drawing paper or in in the
field can be very precise direct and he
could solve problems just like that that
you know who's associate should be
working on that we put this here for the
city income and Norma this wants to be
here they're supposed to be there so and
how did he speak with mr. Miller what
how did he speak to Paul Mellon oh that
was when he spoke to Paul Mellon where
the Kingman Brewster he would get poetic
he would and what drive me nuts because
I'm trying to get them to be
enthusiastic that silence and thresholds
and white and very abstract so Trevor
can you let me advance to this slide
which is what he's talking of the book I
think is it not yes it's very beginning
and Hainish plots is asking the question
can we hear it
it's a building which personifies in the
way how how a structural water must have
the power to unravel itself not as a
design see but as a characteristic okay
it's it's a kind of belief in the
potentiality of man
ruling it's a psychological order as
against a physical but recognizing the
psychological psychological recognizing
that a physical order is what actually
is the major of it but the Willner of it
the will you see you sucker
yes in this case it was the it was
allowing a physical phenomena to unravel
itself you see to a conclusion without
interference
except that knowing it is to be used by
humans
that it is that the spaces which it
means Richard which it unraveled is
useful for you got it but you can see
well you mentioned his using these sort
of dichotomies or pairs and one of them
of course is silence in the light yes
but he also talked about mind versus
brain laws versus rules there are
they're parallel ideas there and this
drawing which he made maybe what are
just coming on yeah this is perhaps his
most famous drawing is just one that he
one peculiarity of it is that Kahn had
the ability to to draw with both hands
and to write with the right mirror
mirror writing so if you see here where
it says silence to light then you see it
coming the other way
here were writing silence to light and
than desire to express and then the
desire to express these they're his
ideas and great and they're very
fundamental ideas what the what the
symbolism is in the upper left hand in
the upper left these lines at least to
me they they did he call he calls them
in his written written here the
inspirations the sanctuary of art the
treasury of the shadows and what it is
it's a kind of platonic world and it
goes back to what Ava was saying the
statement about what was is what was has
always been what is has always been what
will be has always always been yeah
yesterday is today today is tomorrow
tomorrow is today I didn't it's all
there it's a platonic world of ideas so
the architect trying to solve a
particular problem can go into this
realm of ideas and immersing him or
herself and come up with what what it is
that is the sort of ideal form for that
particular need and it's a matter of as
wakhan it's always a matter of reduction
reduce reduce reduce he always he said I
don't try to get back to the number one
I try to get back to the number zero
zero and that becomes clear after a
while so what he really means by it and
why like is so important to him because
I asked my battle once is danced away I
said did you mean like when the first
creatures came out of that tepid pool
and sent to the world that they sensed
light and he said yes that's exactly a
man in the
you read them it's even more than that
because he talks about desire in need
his his thing is then and he desire is
what is human and any any living
organism so that thing comes out of the
water and then feels that there's
something out there and once has an
intense desire to see it he thinks
that's how eyesight develop be sure that
was no desire to see that's the kind of
market that he was you said he was an
intuitive art market that come out not a
logical architect you know no good well
if that so that's what that realm is
then in the center of the pyramid that's
the threshold it's the architect is to
bring those half of that he is to bring
the the idea of what the treasury of the
shadows where their art resides and make
it real bring it into presence make it
present but he uses that that form of
the pyramid which goes back the early
drawing that his early work when he was
at the Academy in Rome terribly
impressed by early Egyptian and Greek
structures as the most important things
in particularly if they're in ruins
because then the structure is revealed
and that's the most important element
but then bring it into into light so the
area on the right is light and give it
to give it presence and that's the task
of the architect so the the ARCA the
architect turns to nature they find the
order meant to go I mean everything in
order
yeah and everything has its order and
I'm just thinking whether was this what
is the order that he was searching so
this is the sense woman it's a simple
instance where I mean the first a zigzag
tower that that was a city tower which
he hoped would be a in Philadelphia he
had terrible time
yeah and it's never bill if he also used
the same idea as a plan for a concrete
building for corporations - yeah but
never was realized the same thing this
tower for Kansas City as with many of
his buildings he had a theory that if
you designed it well enough it didn't
matter what it cost because the donor
the cop with him would come up with it
okay because the ideas were so good
that's why so many of his buildings were
not built so in this one was another one
where the cost came in way higher than
they was expected so yes nature and
nature how can you help me solve this
he says ho so nature gave him a gift of
gravity so instead of building it from
the bottom up he was gonna build it from
the top down so and then just let let
gravity pull all of all the materials
and everything down this was constructor
this is this is a drawing of the idea
but I'm some other comments came up
apropos of this which was interesting
because I think that John you asked him
about context in regard to this building
and he made something an interesting
comment which I thank find a little bit
a little bit hard to parse which is that
if there were buildings around which he
felt needed to be honored then he would
honor them if there weren't then he
would hope that his building would be
honored but he never really defines what
an honorable building is and I find
that's a little bit equivocal and I'm
just kind of kid he never talked about
that with you did he about what what
buildings should be honored and what
buildings you know need not be honored
he never as I say he never talked about
the goals around
in the interviews he does with this
particular building here but in general
he he said I don't like to talk about
other architects and he didn't he talk
about antiquity its own buildings and
his own booming his own and his own
buildings and we had the building soft
was a flat place rather quickly but that
was the building where he wanted to talk
to Paul Mellon to make his sales that he
was the or the architect and so they we
Wow was that the only con building other
than this one that Paul Mellon went to
see well at that time at that time he we
went to Fort Worth just to see Rick
Braun was that was the director of the
Kimbell in Fort Worth was a friend of
mine and he had gone to Harvard and had
very similar ideas and he was doing new
things with light which were in the same
direction that we wanted to go here
although we want to go a little further
and he was going so we did to fly that
fly fly there for to talk to Rick and
see them and see the plans and the model
and then later went down for the opening
I think he was notorious was he not for
not wanting to finish designing I mean
Rick Rama just if there's a comment in
in a piece by Charles Sawyer that I read
where he Rick brown asked him his
opinion Sawyer whether Conn would be a
good architect for the Kimbell as a
response was that you won't find a more
sympathetic humane creative architect
but you've got to be willing to stay up
all night working with him because if
you don't you'll find that he's changed
his mind while you were asleep yeah
and he never wanted to finish a building
because the creation ended yeah I
wouldn't put it quite that way but I
talked to Rick a lot on the phone
because he was really my advisor on
whether to go with karna yeah he would
talk a lot about how to handle them and
and get to get things moving along but
it was it was not that it wasn't that
you didn't want to finish it in fact
when he did finish it I mean he would
say you know I'm satisfied with this
building right that way that was a very
important statement we didn't really
know what we thought of course he would
say any what's it but with Connie
wouldn't say it until he got to we
couldn't blame him but what he did not
mind having to do it over again I was
gonna ask you about that what happened
when the British Art Center scheme had
to be reduced you know we had to reduce
it by a third because it was way over
budget because of he was a time of
runaway inflation and he was not unhappy
with it he you know each year but he was
disappointed because you really loved
that first building which are very
powerful buildings and that would have
been had an interesting different kind
of relationship I think with this
building with this one yeah because it
itself was pretty burly it was but it
was major at any rate he he just he
loved the design and of course he did
that they invited him and when he got
tired and he richest full of his jacket
put on the floor and taking that what he
loved to do with her just to talk about
the building for a second or not the
building but rather the book for a
second were there things in it that
surprised you I mean that's that's
really the great thing about Colin is it
it's a lot that surprised me but where
the surprises come it's just in my own
increased understanding of what he was
about which I didn't really know
when I was working with them I didn't
think you know this is all this great
philosophy stuff going on you know that
we talked about we was all very
practical kind of kind of things when I
was very very innocent about I didn't
really understand you know I said well
we hired this renowned architect and I
waited for those first joints the Kalama
so excited first John's gonna come you
know I expected to see a facade and it
was gonna be beautiful in song so I get
that this square rectangular drawing and
a little little boxes in it rectangles
one would say registrar well as a
curator attendees and it was very
difficult to get out of him any sense of
what I was going to look like eventually
we would get some elevations but most of
his plans plans plans and then some
elevations finally some drawings of
facades but he was very wary of arousing
false expectations he didn't want to do
that and so he just really wouldn't do
it in the models who when he would make
a model was just basswood no color
nothing and the only articulation other
than the forms was that where there's
was war windows was fenestration the
grain is reversed and runs in the other
direction does that's it's a you know we
could we have enough to talk about all
night and I'm just wondering whether we
should just at this point ask people
whether they have some questions because
we've got plenty to talk about but we
don't have time but I'm just wondering
whether there's some questions from the
floor because I suspect that there are
many and
and now is an opportunity I think
probably that mics are out there
somewhere in somebody's hands okay and
did he ever mention young while we're
waiting for a Mike Connor or Melancon no
no no one's melon did I know it I was
that's one of the reasons I asked
because no because I hold hold on a
second but we need a mic just because
you're for posterity now Jules in live
stream according to Vince Callie yeah
so look I'm like a great deal the facade
or the garage well Ibiza was in the
first floor and now alia and that he
composed the proportions of the British
Anson relationship Vince's idea to the
High Street Garage I had a different
theory I know I never heard that at all
if you look if you looked at it from the
parking lot you will see there is a
definite relationship well I think these
things seeped in and where it struck me
remember they the early drawing that was
on here was very sketchy with the arched
roof yep which really shocked me and why
didn't but I realized that at that time
we used to then the airline's fool a lot
between New Haven and Philadelphia and
Stratford and Philadelphia Bridgeport
Stratford and when you fly into the
Stratford Airport there were these
airplane hangars and he used to lie in
there quite regularly
I just wondered whether that image
somehow seeped into it somehow I didn't
know where those I mean that were the
diversity or the arching shape is
something he had used these segmented
arches in a number of places and it's in
the lighting and the Kimbell and the
ya-ya clerestory lighting but you just
wonder about this but Bob you know you
were you were here and and you were
close you were close to Vince and so I
just was wondering what III did I used
to go to Philadelphia quite a few times
as we were doing archival research about
early leucon for Vince's book student
days and all of that cuz nobody knew
anything about it and he he did actually
like to gossip he would talk about other
architects and their work in those days
because I'm talking about 1961 a few 10
years before you got he wasn't quite the
grand man I just want to say
parenthetically also listening to him
doesn't sound like the leucon I knew no
it's funny some people sound exactly as
you expect either you know they're two
things one Eero Saarinen also could draw
that's very interesting was part of
their training it was in their era era
by all reports and the other thing is
the rich who did not like over up on a
professional basis because Paul Rudolph
was the architect just when he arrived
at Yale as the chairman he took on the
commission from Andrew Ritchie to do the
things he was described right that's
really closing the gallery and there was
definite professional animosity which
rudolf regretted later on he never
called kahn and said i'm have been asked
to do this i hope you don't mind the
kind of person
courtesy that is expected so those are
the two things I would add to your may I
don't understand this drawing at all
I've been working at it for two days no
it's flat and art yeah it's a it's a
variable trust system and yeah but it
doesn't need to be curved I mean that's
huh yeah that's taking a walk from the
Kimball which had the clerestory light
over the floor and on the fourth floor
and now we wanted to make this really
great curving clear story light and
that's really the reason why we rejected
this because we felt it would be such a
powerful visual element that your eyes
would leave the paintings and go up to
go to it do you remember that that when
when the alterations were made to the
gallery also they got rid of the stone
at the base of the wall and replaced it
with grass and which was a horrible
thing to do
and I remember Conn coming and giving a
talk after that when it was grass and
just casually in conversation about
something else he said that stone is the
grass of the city and the whole
auditorium erupted because because all
the architects hated the grass and I'm
glad to see that it's gone now because
it never should have been there in the
first entrance both of the galleries
have very interesting solutions to how
to enter them you mean is this one or
the I don't see it here when did that
very much concerned with
the two sides of the building having an
expansion joint in the center yeah the
finals final version the one now yes
quite brilliant the corner yeah yeah
well he had done that at the Richards
and he had done it at Exeter and Exeter
and Kimball are the two immediate
predecessors the centre and that's
fascinating because he was doing a
library and an art gallery which is what
the centre has a lot of both that plus
the academic program so that is
something we had a lot of experience
with it the story though it or at least
as we tell it and when being there at
the time it had to happen is that
Brewster quite specifically said that
the centre should be oriented both
toward the University and the city again
it's within that social context and the
thought was that in fact contact up on
boosters comment to have a corner
entrance that would orient both ways and
it also relates so beautifully to the
interior courtyards it's the same
dimension as the entrance court and it
also relates to the exterior chord which
is the scusi court so there are all
sorts of things that go on at one point
in the design was there not an entrance
off of High Street on axis yeah because
you can look at the plan and see it as a
Bozarth plan if the entrance came off of
High Street well see in this in this
first one that's true the sidewalk goes
past those two Center columns right and
then just flows right through the
building it's a high street yeah and
there was the same thing in the second
building is that it you would you would
enter you would enter and he in the
early plans for the second building in
the same off of the centre of the salon
chapel and the street would go through
in the same kind of way and at one point
you said well cause look at it the other
way come in from High Street but he
rejected
yes there's Carter hey I'm just looking
back at the history of this whole
project and I think it's an
extraordinary tribute to Yale that two
straight arrow
stand-up people like Paul Mellon and
Kingman Brewster would have taken a
chance on this very flaky rather untruth
untested individual and I was curious
who else was on your shortlist and what
you had to do if anything to persuade
these two people to put the power of
Yale and its legacy behind the building
well I think you underestimate both
booster and Mellon in that in that
regard I mean I think booster bringing
co-education to Yale he was he was
willing to do all sorts of things and
and Paul was maybe a little less less
adventurous
than that so let me connect well could
you convince your question a little bit
as to what is that you want to know who
else was on the shortlist who else is on
the shortlist okay the person that I was
very interested in was Phillip Johnson
in part because when I was working at
Harvard at the fog Johnson came in one
day and he wanted to see the plans for
the fog because he had just gotten the
Commission for Utica for the Munson
Williams Proctor and he wanted to build
on the courtyard plan and he wanted the
fog courtyard to be he wanted to have
that in his mind so I like that since I
like the courtyard that like courtyards
that's why I think it got one guy thinks
right that's good so the first place I
really went was to Utica to see the
months of Williams Proctor and I like
the courtyard but I didn't like what he
did he at that stage in his career he
was very decorating decorator it's a bad
word but you know in finicky and little
things would go so yeah the paintings
hanging but then he had a line going
right
middle of them it was just this very
distracted and and so there was it was a
kind of finicky quality to it fact the
one thing that always surprised me about
Phil Johnson buildings the ones that I
saw there and at the Amon Carter and
elsewhere is that when you went down to
the basement and looked at the
engineering was marvelous was just
almost the opposite of this very
filigree kind of stuff that he would do
up above so anyway that he was sort of
running second in the ones that look
that you know I looked at a lot of
others
I had like Richard Myers early work and
he was sort of on my list but that
didn't like some of his later work
Scully was of course very keen on
territory but you know if you think
about the Football Hall of Fame I can
try to put that together with Paul
Noland and that didn't work at all
competition okay Gibson Danes the Dean
of the school of art and architecture
and charles moore the then chairman had
an idea of a competition and there is a
list that they drew up which had
sterling who was very bitter Jim James
sterling about not being considered
after all with you know and he was a
British architect of distinction and
there were others but then obviously you
have the ear of the donor and the
president and they were sort of fiddling
off on the side but there's a huge
literature of letters and so forth and
Vince was writing to the Kingman I've
read Bush pushing I've read them pushing
inventory and inventory was commissioned
at a certain moment to do a kind of
urban design study or the streets of the
whole thing is quite complicated
Yale isn't always as simple as it seems
never it never seems simple to me I hire
an insider hey there's one back there
who I can't see was there a particular
question that was asked that you found
his answer to be most surprising him
question that he asked of you you mean a
question that oh yeah he'd be pretty in
personal conversation oh yeah a lot of
them was like the one about the you know
crawling up out of the water but I guess
the question I always ask them was
what's it gonna look like yeah that's
what I was wanting to know what's it
gonna look like what's it oh that's
different
okay but let me finish that one that I
was just going to say to this cuz I was
just wanted to know what the building
was gonna look like I'm finally yeah he
said what it's you know on a sunny day
it's gonna look like a butterfly and I'm
not a cloudy they don't look like a moth
what was your reaction when he said he
wanted to make it out of steel oh well
that was that was I you know I just kept
saying yeah that was funny because the
early honor yes Mellon did weather
Mellon had any material that he liked
and no one said well nice no I kept like
I asked him you know I remember because
we were driving someplace and I and I
and I asked him I said Lou did you ever
see a metal clad building that you liked
he's no I said but you've got to give us
a metal clad building yes and I have to
say that from the very beginning the one
thing one heard constantly from people
was I love the you know Senator British
art but I don't really like the facade
and I have to say that personally it was
my least favorite part of the building
now it's becoming to me the most
important part of a building it's
extraordinarily important you know I'm
learning more about that facade and what
it's doing and why it's doing what it's
doing I should say it's the most
important but it's it's it's maybe it's
just it's whether it's way ahead of its
time or what or whatever maybe were
growing into it but that whole you think
of back foot back back that drawing of
silence and light I mean that whole
thing is light coming through the glass
UK it's always this binary thing in here
you've got the glass and the metal when
Lou would sometimes refer to them as
windows and opaque windows light no
light and that he viewed matter material
as spent light that is if you could take
if you could take matter and speed it up
as in making a hydrogen bomb why
couldn't you reverse the process slow
the light down
and make it material material and he
said don't talk to scientists about that
they'll say it doesn't work and I tried
tried it on scientist because I get the
illogical it seems logical and Lulu said
no he says it's it's not a scientific
truth it's a poetic truth and that's
equally important did you do you make a
comment once I'm trying to think about
your responsibility being for the soul
of the building and the physical plant
was responsible for what was that that's
a nice phrase well it was one of the
problems I didn't kill me on this one I
mean it seems to be than one of the
problems with this building is that the
architect was his own client so it was
Nurik there was nobody there wasn't that
other he's coming in all the time the
problem with the center and building the
center is that in a funny way there were
too many clients because I was a client
kingman said you're the client
they said Yale's the owner and so
physical plant which is in you know they
do all the engineering although all
mechanical stuff so they be as the thing
progressed they became more and more
important and the sense I had this this
feeling that yeah I was sort of
responsible for the soul of the spirit
of the building but they were
responsible for them for the body of it
they could but but
they were usually overruled first by Lou
and Luis alone alive and then by
Marshall Myers who took over who was
Lou's people that had been the job
captain at the Kimball
they were very strong-willed and would
not be moved easily and often dealing
with engineers Lou through that process
of simplification that I referred to
earlier would reduce the problem that
would bring about a solution which that
they would that they would solve it so
the big big examples the air for the two
great innovations at the center are the
shops first museum ever planned from the
beginning to have commercial shops and
secondly the air floor it's the first my
understanding foot they say it's the
first high-rise building first place
with an air force then use the other
than on grade I'm sure it was Lou
talking to the engineers and saying look
you know I you know the air supply and
because we've got this V V we can leave
ducts in there the other floors where
you don't have V beams you show those
ducts great big it gets off into another
theoretical thing as to why you want
some big because he knows over time
technology's gonna make things smaller
so he said you want to give him room to
submit to do what they want to do
without hurting the structure of the
room which is all-around important one
thing that surprised me I think in
reading through it is that I don't think
commandant his engineer is ever
mentioned no I he didn't say it but just
on that air for thing I think Khan was
saying you know I want to return the air
but I don't want to touch money above
the windows you know how else can we do
it I think his questioning led Abitur to
the idea
of the air for this interesting because
he's very very clear about some things
in the building but he's a little bit
canny about others so that you see the
way the air comes into the building with
all those beautiful dogs but you have no
idea how it's going out the building
does not inflate like a balloon so you
know it's going out somewhere and you
have to look very closely to find a
little reveal in the base there but it's
there it's there but you have to do it
that's the thing about that building is
that everything is revealed
okay any other questions I'm sure that
yes in the back there's a hand up I did
con choose the pyramid to represent the
threshold between silence and light in
the diagram you showed well which term
in the diagram you showed in the
presentation where you have sizes on
light and on the side here shows the
pyramid threshold well it's the for him
that's the fundamental shape I mean it
comes out of those early the early
influence of Egypt in Greece and so on
and the the the whole thing with that
the zigzag tower the city tower is the
tetrahedrons and these things build by
laying them on top of each other this is
pure geometry build build themself
build themselves into a a structure that
doesn't require a spine it's a they do
it themselves
that's all explained in great detail in
in that conversation but yeah you look
at him you say well that that term that
doesn't look like a threshold at all but
that's in his mind that's what it was
doing we have time for maybe one yes
there's a hand in the back did Khan talk
at all about the cylindrical stairwells
their significance and maybe what
inspired them the stairwell is very
important obviously and the fact that
the stairwell does not engage the
ceiling is very important in terms of
sources and that's another question we
didn't get in there we got a lot of
places he always denied being influenced
because he said the word the influence
by Jews means like you've said I'm gonna
copied something it says I never do that
but somewhere in the literature I've
read and like stupidly forgot to make a
note on it he said that the one
influence on and with the British art
said it was carcasonne and when you look
at pictures of it you can see you and
see it and particularly in the stair at
the tower but I can't find it I will
find it something but it I haven't found
it yet
and didn't he do a wonderful drawing of
the absent he'll be which as those
fantastic of things yeah but I mean what
we could talk a lot about that because
there are things that are out there are
you getting thirsty bub would you like
to invite everyone upstairs oh sorry
you
you